.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Demokratie steht in Flammen.
Von einem Tag auf den andern
stirbt in Myanmar die Hoffnung
auf ein Leben
in Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit.
Auch Friedensnobelpreisträgerin
Aung San Suu Kyi
sitzt erneut in Haft.
Es beginnt ein Kampf
um Leben und Tod.
Mittendrin steht plötzlich
auch die Schweizer Diplomatin
Christine Schraner Burgener.
Als Sonderbotschafterin der UNO
wird sie zur letzten Hoffnung
der Bevölkerung in Myanmar.
Fast alleine
kämpft sie mit Willen und Worten
gegen die Waffen der Militärs.
Man darf so ein Mandat
nicht blauäugig annehmen.
Besser man ist überrascht,
wenn etwas gelingt,
als dass man verzweifelt,
weil man nichts hinkriegt.
Man soll eine Brücke sein
und vermitteln,
aber die Dinge wirklich umsetzen,
müssen die Leute vor Ort.
Das müssen sie auch wollen.
Fast ein Jahr
begleite ich die Topdiplomatin
in ihrem unermüdlichen Kampf
gegen Burmas Militärjunta.
Es wird eine Reise
von Bern über Bangkok und Berlin
bis zur UNO in New York.
Of the nine members
in the credential committee
which is composed
of really different member states
who maybe
also have different viewpoints.
Es war ein kurzer Tanz
für Myanmars Demokratie.
Nach zehn Jahren Freiheit
reisst die Armee am 1. Februar 2021
die Macht wieder an sich.
Buchstäblich
hinter dem Rücken des Volkes
lassen die Generäle
die Panzer aufrollen.
Die Welt ist schockiert.
Burma ist nicht länger die
Vorzeigedemokratie in Südostasien.
Myanmar,
wie das Land auch genannt wird,
steht vor einem Scherbenhaufen.
Eine Schweizerin
versucht verzweifelt zu vermitteln.
Es war ein schreckliches Erwachen
für die Menschen in Burma.
Nach zehn Jahren Fortschritt
ein Vollstopp.
Internet und Telefon
funktionieren auf einmal nicht mehr.
Das Militär hat alles abgeschaltet.
Doch ganz überraschend
kam dieser Coup nicht.
Schockierend war er trotzdem.
Auch für mich, der seit Jahren
über die Region berichtet.
Ein Gespräch mit Topdiplomatin
Burgener lässt Böses ahnen.
Es ist ein harter Rückschritt.
Es ist eigentlich eine Katastrophe.
Es wirft das Land
zurück auf die Zeit von 2011,
als man auf 50 Jahre Militärdiktatur
zurückschaute,
auf die Isolation eines Landes,
in dem die Leute in Angst lebten
und keine Rechte hatten.
Jetzt ist es wieder so weit.
Es folgen Tage des Protests,
der Verunsicherung und der Wut.
V.a. die junge Generation
kämpft friedlich
um das zarte Pflänzchen
der Demokratie.
* Melancholischer Gesang *
Weit weg vom burmesischen Yangon,
im beschaulichen Bern,
laufen in den Tagen des Bangens
die Drähte heiss.
Nicht etwa im Bundeshaus,
sondern in der Wohnung
der Familie Schraner Burgener.
Hoi, Christine. Ja, hallo.
- Hallo.
Ist das noch der aus Thailand?
- Ja, der Thai-Hund.
Es ist ein Wiedersehen
nach langer Zeit.
Wir kennen uns aus den Jahren,
als sie Botschafterin in Thailand war
und sind mittlerweile per Du.
2018 wurde sie
Sonderbotschafterin für die UNO.
Seither
habe ich sie nie mehr gesehen.
Um ihre Arbeit nicht zu gefährden,
mied die Diplomatin
den Kontakt zu Journalisten.
Der Coup hat nun alles verändert.
Nach diesem Coup fand ich,
dass ich weder etwas ausbalancieren,
noch das Vertrauen der Leute
gewinnen muss.
Ich muss einfach laut werden.
Es ist wichtig zu sagen,
dass wir das verurteilen.
Ich möchte möglichst schnell
mit der Armee sprechen.
Ich bin jetzt anscheinend
immer noch fast die Einzige,
die noch Kontakt mit der Armee hat.
In der kleinen Wohnung, in der sie
mit ihrem Mann und ihrem Sohn lebt,
wird gerade Weltpolitik gemacht.
Die Pandemie
zwingt die Diplomatin ins Homeoffice.
Wochenlang
zieht sie von hier in Bern
die Fäden zwischen Myanmar
und dem Rest der Welt.
Die UNO hofft, dass die Botschafterin
so bald wie möglich
nach Myanmar reisen kann,
um dort die Generäle zu treffen.
Ich wiederhole meinen Aufruf
an die Militärregierung,
der Sondergesandten und Botschafte-
rin Christine Schraner Burgener
Zugang zu Myanmar zu gewähren.
Immer mehr
beschäftigt Burmas Schicksal
auch
die grossen Player der Weltbühne.
Die geplante Reise
der UNO-Botschafterin nach Myanmar
wird zunehmend zu einer
delikaten geopolitischen Frage.
Letzte Woche telefonierte ich
mit dem UNO-Generalsekretär.
Er meinte, ich solle
mit den Amerikanern sprechen,
um sicher zu sein,
dass sie am gleichen Strick
wie die Chinesen ziehen.
Jetzt müssen wir das abwarten.
Ich warte jetzt auf New York.
Aber es kann ja immer noch sein,
dass die Armee auch dann Nein sagt
und ich gar nicht reinkomme.
Darum möchte ich wenigstens
schon mal nach Thailand.
Noch sitzt sie in Bern fest.
Fünf Wochen
sind seit dem Coup vergangen
und manchmal
kommen Wut und Zweifel auf.
Du hast gesagt,
die Leute würden langsam wütend.
Es breitet sich eine Wut aus
unter den Leuten.
Du hast jetzt drei Jahre lang
einen Friedensprozess begleitet
und jetzt bist du
eigentlich fast in einem Krieg.
Ja.
- Wie geht es dir damit?
Am 1.2. war ich extrem traurig
für die Leute.
Dann kam auch dieser Moment,
als ich nur noch wütend war.
Ich versuche immer,
meine Emotionen zu kontrollieren,
weil das Energie braucht.
Das ist das Motto
meines ganzen Lebens,
nicht nur in dieser Phase.
Ich bin überzeugt davon,
dass negative Gedanken
einem die Energie wegnehmen.
Darum sage ich mir immer wieder:
"Fokussiere dich auf das,
was du machen kannst
und versuch, dein Bestes zu geben."
Den Kopf hängen zu lassen
liegt nicht drin,
wenn Burmas Demokratie
wieder blühen soll.
Es sind lange Tage.
Nach Telefonkonferenzen
von Yangon bis New York
steht heute noch ein Auftritt
in der Talksendung "Club"
beim Schweizer Fernsehen an.
Wir fahren nach Zürich
und haben Zeit,
über unsere gemeinsamen Jahre
in Thailand zu sprechen.
Als ich dich zum ersten Mal sah,
waren wir in Thailand,
auch mitten in einem Konflikt.
Kannst du das
in deine jetzige Arbeit einbringen?
Kannst du etwas dazu sagen?
Ohne Thailand hätte ich mich nie
für den Posten in Myanmar beworben.
Ich habe fast fünf Jahre in Thailand
für die Schweiz vermittelt.
Das konnte ich im Stillen machen.
Es gibt immer die stille Diplomatie,
wenn wir
unsere guten Dienste anbieten.
Das ist jetzt ganz anders,
weil ich jetzt
in der Öffentlichkeit bekannt bin.
Das ist jetzt etwas schwieriger.
Aber ich habe vieles gelernt.
Z.B. wie man verhandelt
und dass man Geduld haben muss.
Man muss v.a. realpolitisch
und geostrategisch denken.
Welche Beziehung hat das
z.B. mit China und Thailand?
Da ich schon in Asien
verhandelt habe,
verfüge ich vielleicht über einen
Rucksack, der nützlich sein kann.
Wir sind in Zürich.
Gleich beginnt
die Aufzeichnung der Talksendung.
Christine Schraner Burgener
soll über ihre Erfahrungen
mit Diktaturen reden.
Noch vor der Sendung
kriegen wir eine Kostprobe davon,
wie unberechenbar
solche Regime sein können.
Es ist eine beunruhigende Nachricht
aus Myanmar:
Die Polizei hat das Büro
der lokalen Mitarbeiter umzingelt.
"There are a lot of police
around my house now."
Das war vor 10 Min.
"In case the police come in, should
I destroy my phone and laptop?"
Sofort alarmiert Burgener das
Sicherheitsteam der UNO in New York.
Hallo. Ich bin sehr besorgt.
Sie schrieben,
die Polizei sei beim Haus,
und sie befürchten,
dass sie reinkommen werden.
Sie fragen, ob sie das Telefon
und den Laptop zerstören sollen.
Es verstreichen bange Minuten.
Shit.
Es macht mich nervös,
dass sie nicht mehr antwortet.
Und dann die erlösende Nachricht:
Hat sie geschrieben?
- Ja.
"Ich konnte nicht rangehen."
"Ich war auf dem Dach, um den Laptop
und das Telefon zu verstecken."
Die Arme stieg auf das Dach.
Die kennt nichts.
Fällt dir ein Stein vom Herzen?
Ja, aber sie
sind natürlich noch nicht weg.
Wenigstens
hat sie den Laptop versteckt.
Ja. Mein Gott. Nein.
Es sind solche Momente,
die Schraner Burgener antreiben,
weiterzumachen.
Noch einmal kurz durchatmen
und schon beginnt die Fernsehsendung.
Guten Abend
und willkommen im "Club".
Bei mir
ist Christine Schraner Burgener,
UNO-Sonderbeauftragte für Burma.
In Burma würden massivste Menschen-
rechtsverletzungen vorfallen.
Die Proteste begannen nach
dem Militärputsch am 1. Februar.
Die Armee sagte, es habe bei den
Parlamentswahlen Wahlbetrug gegeben.
Sie setzten die Regierung dann ab.
Sie versuchen, nach Myanmar
zu kommen und dort zu verhandeln.
Der UNO-Sicherheitsrat
lancierte ein Statement,
man begrüsse Ihre Präsenz dort.
Warum können Sie nicht einreisen?
Ich habe schon vor fünf Wochen,
als der Coup stattgefunden hat,
mit der Armee telefoniert.
Ich hatte
eine dreistündige Videokonferenz
mit dem Deputy Commander,
der Nummer 2 der Armee.
Ich sagte dort schon, dass ich so
schnell wie möglich kommen möchte.
Er sagte Nein,
es sei momentan nicht der Zeitpunkt.
Sie müssten weitere Untersuchungen
zum Wahlbetrug machen.
Und sie wollten auch die Bewegung
des zivilen Ungehorsams,
des Civil Disobedience Movement,
beenden.
Mit anderen Worten: Sie wollen
die Leute von der Strasse haben.
Dann könne ich kommen.
Wenn die Situation friedlicher sei.
Doch friedlicher
wird die Situation nicht.
Drei Wochen später ist es so weit.
Die Sonderbotschafterin fliegt
erstmals seit dem Putsch nach Asien.
Zuerst allerdings nur nach Thailand,
denn nach wie vor
wollen die burmesischen Generäle
sie nicht ins Land lassen.
Offizieller Grund ist die Pandemie.
Wie spielt Corona
in deine Arbeit rein?
Erschwert es das zusätzlich?
Extrem. Ohne Corona
wäre ich schon lange in Myanmar.
Dann bräuchte ich
gar keine Einreisebewilligung,
weil ich ja ein Visum habe.
Gerade heute Morgen erhielt ich
ein Nein auf die Frage ...
... ob ich
möglichst schnell einreisen könne.
Sie wollen dich momentan
also nicht dort haben.- Genau.
Die Pandemie ist eine willkommene
Ausrede für die Generäle.
Ganz abbrechen
wollen sie den Kontakt aber nicht.
Sie sind daran interessiert,
mit mir in Kontakt zu bleiben.
Die Kommunikation ist
noch nicht ganz abgebrochen.- Nein.
Die Junta
ist extrem wütend auf mich.
Das haben sie ja publiziert.
Sie haben rund drei Zeitungsseiten
über mich vollgeschrieben.
Ich liege in allem falsch.
Das muss sich erst mal legen.
Verärgert sind die Generäle
v.a. über den Klartext,
den Schraner Burgener spricht,
und dass sie
die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
und Gräueltaten anprangert.
Vor Ort in Burma hat sich die Lage
in der Zwischenzeit zugespitzt.
Das Militär
demonstriert ganz unverfroren
seine wiedererlangte Macht.
Die UNO spricht vom blutigsten Tag
seit dem Putsch Anfang Februar.
Vor wenigen Tagen haben Soldaten
auf Demonstranten geschossen.
Mindestens 90 Zivilisten
kamen dabei ums Leben.
Entspannung ist keine in Sicht.
Die vom Volk so geliebte
Demokratieikone Aung San Suu Kyi
hat nichts mehr zu sagen.
Seit dem Coup sitzt sie in Haft.
Die Friedensnobelpreisträgerin
war auch für Christine Schraner
Burgeners Arbeit eine wichtige Figur.
Bis zum Putsch hatten die beiden
regelmässig Kontakt.
Wir sprachen letztes Mal darüber,
dass du noch mal versuchst,
mit der Schlüsselfigur
Aung San Suu Kyi Kontakt aufzunehmen.
Was ist in der Zwischenzeit passiert?
Was weisst du von ihr?
Ich weiss von ihrem Anwalt, dass er
sie virtuell noch mal gesehen hat.
Er konnte aber
nicht aktiv mit ihr sprechen.
Aber es scheint ihr gut zu gehen.
Sie hat jetzt
noch mehr Anwälte engagiert.
Insgesamt
hat sie jetzt sechs Anwälte.
Sie wird sicher nicht aufgeben.
Ich werde auch nicht aufgeben
und werde weiterhin sagen,
ich wolle sie sehen.
Letzten Montag schickte ich
ein Schreiben an die Armee,
und sagte, ich wolle jetzt kommen
und sie auch sehen.
Wie lange Schraner Burgener
in Asien bleibt, ist offen.
Sie rechnet mit bis zu zwei Monaten.
Ihr Job als UNO-Botschafterin
verlangt viel Flexibilität.
Ich musste überlegen,
was ich packen soll.
Ich weiss ja nicht,
wie lange ich bleibe.
Aber ziemlich sicher zwei Monate.
Du bist jetzt zwei Monate weg von
deiner Familie. Wie nehmen sie das?
Es ist ganz cool, sie sind
sich das von vorher gewöhnt.
Ich war natürlich jeweils
nicht zwei Monate am Stück weg.
Ich hatte immer volle Unterstützung,
v.a. von meinem Mann.
Und auch von meinem Sohn.
Ich habe ihm heute Morgen
extra ein Brot gemacht,
weil er jetzt arbeitet.
Ich sagte, ich mache das,
damit sie mich wirklich vermissen.
Ziel der Reise nach Asien
ist ein Treffen mit den Generälen.
Die Diplomatin hofft,
die Militärs mit Gesprächen
doch noch zum Umdenken zu bewegen.
Sei es mit Argumenten
oder mit dem Druck von Sanktionen.
Die Erfolgschancen
sind jedoch gering.
Die Reise nach Bangkok
ist auch eine Reise
zurück in die eigene Vergangenheit.
Bangkok war ihre erste Stelle
als Botschafterin für die Schweiz.
Und es gab noch ein anderes Novum:
Zum ersten Mal
schickte die Eidgenossenschaft
ein Paar im Jobsharing
auf einen Aussenposten.
Alle Welt spricht von Jobsharing.
Die Schweiz
spricht nicht nur darüber,
sie macht es der Welt vor und geht
völlig neue diplomatische Wege.
In der Schweizer Botschaft
in Thailand
teilt sich seit Freitag nämlich
ein Ehepaar den Botschafterposten.
Pascal Nufer
hat das Teilzeit-Beschäftigtenpaar
einen Tag lang in Bangkok begleitet.
Seit Freitag sind die neuen
Botschafter in Thailand im Amt:
das Ehepaar Burgener Schraner.
Zu zweit teilen sie sich eine Stelle,
die bis anhin
von einer Person betreut wurde.
Sawadee ka.
- Sawadee ka. Kap khun ka. And you?
Zehn Tage sind vergangen
seit ihrem Abflug aus Zürich.
Zehn Tage, die Schraner Burgener
in Quarantäne verbracht hat
und in denen sie Zeit hatte,
möglichst viele Treffen
zu organisieren.
Das ist vom Aussenministerium.
- Wunderbar.
Bis zum Abendessen heute Abend.
Die Restaurants sind ja zu.- Genau.
Genau.
- Alles Gute.
Wunderbar.
Wichtig ist ihr auch ein Besuch
an ihrem ehemaligen Arbeitsort,
der Schweizer Botschaft in Bangkok.
* Ruhige, thailändische Musik *
Sawadee ka.
Das ist wie Heimkommen.
Ich wohnte ja sechs Jahre hier.
Es war eine fantastische Zeit.
Sehr spannend.
Damals waren ja die Unruhen hier,
Fluten und dann der Militärputsch.
Von der Arbeit her
war das eine sehr spannende Zeit.
Wenn man sechs Jahre
mit der Familie hier wohnt,
als die Kinder
noch zur Schule gingen ...
Jetzt wohnen sie ja
nicht mehr zu Hause.
Das sind so schöne Erinnerungen.
Ich bin einfach
sehr gern in Thailand.
Doch es
geht nicht nur um Erinnerungen.
Im Zentrum steht auch hier
die Situation in Myanmar.
Wir werden noch viel über die
Situation der Geflüchteten sprechen.
Wir haben uns schon
mit dem UNHCR getroffen.
Ihr Wissen über die Region
kommt der Diplomatin jetzt zugute.
Ihre Kontakte öffnen ihr
auch heute noch viele Türen.
Sie trifft UNO-Vertreter, Diplomaten,
Menschenrechtsorganisationen
und Journalisten.
Immer mit dem Ziel,
eine gemeinsame Strategie zu finden,
um die Generäle
doch noch zum Einlenken zu bringen.
Jetzt gehen wir zu den Amerikanern.
Zum Chargé,
das ist wie der Botschafter.
Das wird
ein dreiviertelstündiges Gespräch.
Mal schauen. Die Amerikaner
haben grosses Interesse an Myanmar.
Auf dem Weg
zur amerikanischen Botschaft
gerät
der lokale Mitarbeiter der Diplomatin
regelrecht ins Schwärmen.
Die Sondergesandte
ist eine Super-Diplomatin
und eine aussergewöhnliche Mentorin.
Es ist ein Privileg.
Ihr Arbeitsethos ist unglaublich.
Sie arbeitet 20 Std. am Tag.
Wir versuchen mitzuhalten
und unterstützen sie, wo es geht.
Amerika spielt eine wichtige Rolle
in Myanmar.
Zu diesem Besuch
geht die Sonderbotschafterin allein.
Journalisten sind nicht zugelassen.
Die Zeit vergeht wie im Fluge.
Es ist bereits Mai.
In Myanmar
ist keine Entspannung in Sicht.
Christine Schraner Burgener
ist immer noch in Asien.
In einem Videointerview zieht sie
für die "Tagesschau" Zwischenbilanz.
Ich finde, es hat sich sehr gelohnt.
Ich konnte doch gewisse Treffen
von Angesicht zu Angesicht machen,
nicht nur virtuell.
So kann man auch besser
Vertraulichkeiten austauschen.
In der Zwischenzeit
gelang ihr ein kleiner Durchbruch.
Sie konnte nach Jakarta fliegen
und tatsächlich
den burmesischen General treffen.
Ich war eigentlich die Einzige,
die ein bilaterales Treffen
mit ihm halten konnte.
Alle anderen
haben es im ASEAN-Verbund gemacht.
So konnte ich ihm
auch viel mehr sagen,
was uns bedrückt und wo wir
einen Protest aussprechen.
Doch trotz des Gesprächs
bleiben die Aussichten düster.
Die Diplomatin darf nicht einreisen
und sitzt weiter fest.
Die einzige Möglichkeit,
burmesische Zivilisten zu treffen,
bietet sich schliesslich in Bangkok.
Eine Gruppe geflüchteter Journalisten
will die Sonderbotschafterin
in einem geheimen Haus empfangen.
Aus Angst vor Repressionen
haben sie sich nach dem Putsch
nach Thailand abgesetzt.
Jetzt beobachten sie die Situation
aus der Ferne.
Six months.
- Yes, and ...
Every six months.
- Okay, every six months.
But you know ...
- It's mint tea.- Thank you.
It's a wait and see position
for those who ...
Die Journalisten hoffen,
dass die UNO-Sonderbotschafterin auch
ihre Situation weitertragen kann.
Was ist denn für Sie
die grösste Herausforderung?
That is what we want to know.
Es sind solche Treffen,
für die Christine Schraner Burgener
ihren Job liebt.
Ich habe das immer gemacht,
sogar als Botschafterin.
Ich ging immer zu den Leuten.
Da erfährt man meistens
auch immer sehr spannende Dinge.
Man kann vieles delegieren,
was auch gut ist.
Ich bin gerne auch Teamplayerin,
aber ich bin auch gerne
bei den Leuten und höre das 1:1.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der Weg zum Frieden in Myanmar
bleibt steinig.
Trotz aller Bemühungen
bleibt der Sonderbotschafterin
ein Zugang zum Land
weiterhin verwehrt.
Fast ein halbes Jahr ist
seit dem Besuch in Bangkok vergangen.
Die Situation
hat sich kaum verändert.
In Berlin treffen wir
Christine Schraner Burgener wieder.
Hier war sie Schweizer Botschafterin,
bevor sie den Job bei der UNO annahm.
Bald endet ihr Mandat.
Die letzten Wochen als
Sonderbotschafterin haben begonnen.
Stehen wir ein bisschen
vor einem Scherbenhaufen?
Der fing
natürlich schon am 1. Februar an.
Wir hatten noch die Hoffnung,
dass wir das Ruder
noch irgendwie herumreissen können.
Was gut ist:
Keine Seite will aufgeben.
D.h., dass wir
immer noch eine Chance haben,
auf den Weg der Demokratisierung
zurückzufinden.
* Handy *
Hallo.
Hallo, Justine.
Um 16 Uhr
sind wir beim Brandenburger Tor.
Dann können wir uns dort treffen.
Ja, danke vielmals.
Bis nachher. Tschau. Tschau-tschau.
Sie ist mein ganzer Stolz,
meine Tochter.
Bevor sie ihre Tochter treffen kann,
die hier in Berlin studiert,
wartet ein mit Terminen vollbepackter
Tag auf die Diplomatin.
Vom Deutschen Auswärtigen Amt
bis hin zum Schweizer Botschafter.
Selbst über Mittag ist
die UNO-Sondergesandte eingespannt
und hält noch kurz einen Vortrag.
Ihre zunehmende Enttäuschung über die
Lage in Myanmar wird immer spürbarer.
Ich bin leider sehr pessimistisch
für dieses Land eingestellt.
Keine der beiden Seiten
will aufgeben.
Es besteht also noch Hoffnung.
Die Hoffnung
für die Kinder in Myanmar,
dass sie
keine Lost Generation werden,
sondern, dass wir das Rad
noch umdrehen können.
Mit im Saal sitzt auch
ein alter Weggefährte: Paul Seger.
Er ist heute
Schweizer Botschafter in Berlin
und war zuvor selber
drei Jahre Botschafter in Myanmar.
Das eine ist, dass die Situation
dort unten sehr schwierig ist.
Das andere ist, dass wir eine Person
wie Christine Schraner haben,
die mit vollem Einsatz versucht,
das Schlimmste zu verhindern
und den Dialog
womöglich noch zu pflegen.
Und v.a. - was sehr wichtig ist
für die Leute dort -
internationale Unterstützung
zu mobilisieren.
Der Tag ist gut gelaufen.
Am Brandenburger Tor
wird Christine Schraner Burgener
bereits von ihrer Tochter erwartet.
Sofort wird aus der Topdiplomatin
eine stolze Mutter.
Hallo.
Hoi.
Und?
Es ist lustig, alle aus Bangkok
immer wieder zu treffen.- Ja.
Auch ich kenne Tochter Justine
noch aus der Zeit in Bangkok.
Für mich ist es "leider",
aber es ist immer wieder schön,
an einen schönen Ort zu gehen,
um sie zu sehen.
Sie hat jetzt hier fertig studiert
und wird wohl versuchen,
den Anwalt zu machen.
Für eine diplomatische Karriere?
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
* Lachen *
Nein.
Es ist zwar schön,
aber nichts für mich.
Durch ihre Diplomatenlaufbahn
ist Christine Schraner Burgener
schon weit in der Welt rumgekommen,
immer in Begleitung ihrer Familie.
Und da, wo die ist,
sei auch sie zu Hause.
Ich fühle mich schnell irgendwo wohl
und zu Hause.
Das habe ich
ihnen auch weitergegeben.
Du hast dich sofort
überall wohlgefühlt:
in Bangkok, in Berlin, in Dublin ...
- Ja.
In Bern auch.
Da war sie auch lange.
Wo ist heute dein Zuhause?
- Das ist schwierig.
Bern ist schon noch Heimat,
aber jetzt
bin ich in Berlin zu Hause.
Denkst du, du hast etwas vermisst,
weil du so oft umgezogen bist?
Oder war das einfach anders?
Es hat Vor- und Nachteile.
Der Nachteil ist, dass man
nie einen besten Freundeskreis hat.
Aber die Vorteile überwiegen
im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich schon.
Christine Schraner Burgener
muss zurück nach Bern,
um ihre letzte Reise für die UNO
vorzubereiten.
Ein allerletztes Mal fliegt sie nach
New York an den Hauptsitz der UNO.
Christine Schraner Burgener
ist im Endspurt ihrer Zeit
als Sondervermittlerin
der Vereinten Nationen.
In Myanmar ist derweil kein
Ende der Gewaltherrschaft in Sicht.
Ich hatte um 7 Uhr
schon Meetings mit Myanmar.
Im ersten
gab es eine schlechte Meldung.
Jemand sehr Bekanntes
wurde verhaftet.
Er war eigentlich die Nummer 2
der Disobedience-Bewegung.
Wir versuchten sofort,
etwas Alarm zu schlagen,
aber anscheinend
ist das Schlimmste schon passiert.
Er wurde in der Nacht
wohl so stark gefoltert,
dass er jetzt
im Spital im Koma liegt.
Wir haben jetzt noch versucht,
das IKRK einzuschalten.
Aber das
ist natürlich extrem schlimm.
Solche Meldungen gehen ihr auch nach
Monaten intensiver Arbeit noch nah.
Sie sind der Beweis dafür,
dass selbst Spitzendiplomaten
wenig ausrichten können
gegen skrupellose Generäle.
Es schmerzt
Christine Schraner Burgener, dass sie
nicht mehr für die Burmesinnen
und Burmesen erreichen konnte.
Das ist natürlich schlimm
und tut weh, ja.
Aber vielleicht ...
... ist es wieder eine Chance,
dass jemand Neues
auch wieder neuen Wind reinbringt.
Und so etwas
zieht einen natürlich auch runter.
Ich hatte jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre
fast keine Pause und kaum Ferien.
Wenn man immer nur Leid sieht,
braucht man auch mal eine Pause.
Und besser, man macht das früher,
bevor es zu spät ist.
Es ist Zeit, Abschied zu nehmen.
Von New York, aber auch von Myanmar,
das hier im Central Park
kaum weiter weg sein könnte.
Dreieinhalb Jahre versuchte
die Sonderbotschafterin vergebens,
dem Land Demokratie zu bringen.
Was bleibt, ist ein Scherbenhaufen
und Erinnerungen.
Erinnerungen
an das Land der goldenen Pagoden.
Ein Land,
das geprägt ist von alten Kulturen.
Burma,
wie man das Land früher nannte,
ist auch ein Land, das immer
wieder mit seiner Geschichte haderte.
Z.B. mit der Geschichte der
muslimischen Minderheit der Rohingya.
Auch für diese setzte sich
Schraner Burgener immer wieder ein -
wie hier
bei einem Besuch für die UNO 2018.
Es sind aber auch Erinnerungen
an noch frühere Zeiten.
An 2012 z.B., als man an eine
grosse Zukunft für Myanmar glaubte.
Die Schweiz
gehörte zu den ersten Ländern,
die dort im Beisein
des damaligen Aussenministers
eine neue Botschaft eröffneten.
Das ist ein Neustart
für die Beziehungen
zwischen der Schweiz und Myanmar.
Myanmar kann jetzt
die Menschenrechte wiederentdecken,
seine Wirtschaft zum Blühen bringen
und an diesem historischen
Moment wollen wir Teil haben.
Der erste Schweizer Botschafter
von Myanmar war damals kein anderer
als Christine Schraner Burgeners
Mann, Christoph Burgener.
Es ist ein emotionaler Moment
für die bilateralen Beziehungen
zwischen der Schweiz und Myanmar -
und auch für mich.
Ich bin sehr stolz darauf,
der erste residente Botschafter
hier in Myanmar zu sein.
Die Aufbruchsstimmung
war überwältigend.
Man glaubte an Demokratie, Freiheit
und ein wirkliches Ende
einer Schreckensherrschaft.
Meine Frau, Christine.
- Wunderschön.
Danke. So wie ich?
Er ist auch sehr bescheiden.
All dies liegt heute weit zurück.
Ein weiteres Mal versinkt das Land
der goldenen Pagoden
in den dunklen Schatten der Diktatur.
Zurück in New York.
Christine Schraner Burgener ist auf
der Zielgeraden ihrer UNO-Laufbahn.
Es bleibt noch eine Woche,
um ihr Mandat als Sonderbotschafterin
abzuschliessen.
Noch ein letztes Mal
eilt die Spitzendiplomatin
von Termin zu Termin.
Auch nach dreieinhalb Jahren
ist das Problem immer noch
die Macht des Militärs.
Es sind Tage des Abschieds
und des Zurückschauens.
Zum Abschluss trifft sie
ein letztes Mal ihren Chef,
den UNO-Generalsekretär
António Guterres.
Sie gehen nun also zurück nach Bern.
- Ja. Aber ich bin sehr traurig.
Danke schön.
Leider ist heute ein trauriger Tag.
Wir müssen Abschied nehmen
von einer ausserordentlichen
UNO-Botschafterin.
Sie hat einen fantastischen Job
geleistet für die Leute in Myanmar.
Sie haben dort enorm von ihrem Mut,
ihrer Entschlossenheit
und ihren Prinzipien profitiert.
Aber auch die UNO
hat unglaublich von ihr profitiert.
Alle, die mit der Myanmarkrise
zu tun haben,
respektieren unsere Arbeit
dank der Leistung unserer
exzellenten Sonderbotschafterin.
Niemand hätte diese Arbeit
besser machen können als Christine.
Jetzt müssen wir
ohne sie zurechtkommen.
Schöne Worte,
doch die Realität ist bitter:
Auch eine UNO-Sonderbotschafterin
ist machtlos
gegenüber der Willkür einer Junta.
Schraner Burgener zieht weiter.
Sie wird jetzt die erste Chefin
des Staatssekretariats
für Migration der Schweiz.
Ich freue mich darüber,
wieder mal in Bern zu Hause zu sein.
Ich bin sehr gerne in der Schweiz.
Ich werde trotzdem noch reisen.
Die Migrationspolitik hat
auch viel mit dem Ausland zu tun,
v.a. mit unseren Nachbarländern.
Und so werden ihre Reisen von nun an
wohl etwas kürzer werden.
Sicher ist: Auch in ihrem neuen Job
wird ihr die Arbeit nicht ausgehen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022